[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bonne semaine
et puis bon jour j mee notre invité ce
matin dans 16 autres caddie et raf
montplaisir bonjour bonjour ne chez
caruge et bonjour tout et auditrices et
auditeurs vous êtes le maire de casse
pilote est également président du ce
même le syndicat mixte de l'ex lycées de
martinique c'est à ces deux titres que
vous ne nous vous recevons ce matin
alors ras font plaisir il ya quelques
semaines on vous avez vu devant les
caméras annoncé que vous mettiez en
place un centre de vaccination sur le
territoire de case-pilote où en est on
aujourd'hui ce qu'il y a eu des
vaccinations est ce que ce centre
fonctionne à écouter un très simplement
je vous dirais que nous sommes prêts
j'ai adressé un courrier à monsieur le
préfet à la rs le directeur de la rs a
eu l'amabilité de me répondre très
cordialement pour m'informer que notre
motivation 15 pilotes étaient pour lui
quelque chose de positif et qu'il
gardait sa en mémoire pour que le moment
venu dès qu'il serait prêt à distribuer
des vaccins à des centres de vaccination
eh ben il pourrait penser à quinze
pilotes mais on est prêts on attend et
j'ai eu des également monsieur le préfet
qui m'a qui nous a félicités ça m'a
touché parce que il nous a dit votre
votre initiative a été très positive
volontarisme mais qu'est ce que vous
vouliez montrer finalement à d'abord à
vos administrés mais à la population
martiniquaise en étant en voulant sous
vous montrez pionnier en quelque sorte
dans cette affaire de vaccination contre
le lakovic 19 et un goûter
1 je pense que ce qu'il faut surtout
c'est essayer d'être positif dans la vie
nous avons un problème mondial
le remède ou le frein semble être le
vaccin et comme j'ai je me plais à dire
je ne veux pas que le vaccin m'attendre
je souhaite attendre le vaccin moi je
l'attends physiquement mais j'estime que
toute la population
en tout cas toutes celles et ceux qui
souhaitent être vaccinés puisse avoir un
endroit
ou se présenter parce que ce serait
dommage que on est des vaccins et qu'on
est nulle part ou à pratiquer cette
petite intervention
alors parlons encore de case-pilote quel
est le chantier finalement en tant que
maire qui vous occupe en ce moment on
voit des travaux qui ont débuté du côté
de vous savez derrière choiseul là il ya
un projet de zone commerciale
d'activités commerciales et puis je
crois qu'il ya un centre de débit
numérique qui est en train d'être
réalisé vous voyez les travaux c'est la
nouvelle caserne des pompiers de crise
filote ken allemann ans le chantier on
l'espère pour le milieu de l'année où
tous les cas début du deuxième semestre
pouvoir inaugurer et nous remercions le
ch'ti c'est la ctm de cette action très
positive pour le nord caraïbes et
notamment pour calvi lot il ya le projet
de zone d'activité commerciale enfin de
tout ce qu'il ya dans cet oiseau de la
zone est en cours de réalisation
nous avons d'ailleurs un petit centre
médical qui devrait être construit nous
avons promoteurs et nous avons médecin
on a de ce que le promoteur m'a laissé
entendre il ya un laboratoire qui est en
train de réfléchir à être présent nous
avons un cardiologue généralistes comme
ça s'appelle infirmières fin on a
beaucoup de gens puis à d'autres
activités qui doivent venir sur cette
zone d activité commerciale qui devrait
amener une vie économique
super supplémentaires à case-pilote et
de l'emploi pour le nord caraïbes et
notamment classes pilotes alors on va
parler un peu de d'économie parce que en
dehors de vos mandats électifs on sait
que vous êtes aussi chef d'entreprise et
dans le dos dans un acteur économique
avec
le groupe monplaisir en martinique c'est
la crise incite à la crise sanitaire
crise sociale d'abord mais économique
qui touche notamment le tourisme
l'hôtellerie mais d'autres secteurs de
l'économie
comment voient ils savent où le
responsable politique que vous êtes et
ed et moi je vais vous dire quelque
chose on est sur une île
des fois c'est dommageable des fois
c'est plus intéressant parce qu'on ferme
plus facilement des frontières d'une
dune il que d'un pays dans un continent
aujourd'hui la martinique vie sont sa
situation de qu'ovide du mieux qu'elle
le peut mais il est certain que
l'économie ne peut pas ne pas en
souffrir elle notamment l'hôtellerie le
tourisme absolument des restaurants
enfin bon tout à fait toute une filière
kwajalein filière nous avons eu un petit
une petite soupapes en fin d'année avec
le tourisme qui a permis aux hôtels et
autres de fonctionner les restaurants
aujourd'hui les restaurants sont ouverts
jusqu'à une certaine en tous les cas et
ils sont occupés les gens y vont c'est
bien mais vous savez je vais vous dire
personne ne peut dire quoi que ce soit
sur l'économie
nulle part dans le monde parce que ce
cette pandémie évolué dans un sens ou un
autre
tellement rapidement en l'espace d'une
semaine vous fait des pointes vers le
haut dix jours après ça redescend
doucement ça remonte ses excuses et la
comparution mais c'est comme une fièvre
ça monte ça descend
vous ne pouvez pas youtube on ne peut
pas gérer une école bien que c'est
finalement un défi inédit qu'on doit
relever
pratiquement au jour le jour quoi oui et
c'est une expérience qui à mon avis
risque de ne pas être à la première
c'est pas la première fois qu'on a des
pandémies
nous avons eu la grippe espagnole et
tout ça mais à la différence du monde
d'aujourd'hui les gens ne se déplaçait
pas aussi vite aussi autant aujourd'hui
le monde est devenu petit le monde et le
monde c'est un seul ensemble et de ce
fait toute pandémie qui va apparaître
aujourd'hui n'importe où dans le monde
va
on l'a dit plus tôt qu'il va apparaître
va va être transportée très bientôt
c'est la rançon de la modernisation tout
ça c'est une leçon il faut qu'on
apprenne à en sortir il y aura des
élections pour la collectivité
territoriale de martinique dans quelques
mois bon c'est là c'est programmé pour
juin mais on verra bien si ça sera
repoussée de quelques mois
tout ça se prépare vous même comment
parce que s'il ya de l'eau dans le gaz
dans le grand ensemble et pumba pays en
chance faut rappeler que vous étiez une
des chevilles ouvrières 1 qui aviez mis
ça en place pour la première élection à
ces thèmes en 2015
bon l'alliance a volé en éclats écoutez
vous savez on peut pas aller contre la
nature humaine et les hommes ont
toujours les dames et les hommes ont
toujours tendance à être humain donc
rien n'est jamais parfait
ce que je trouve dommageable est triste
c'est que tout ça apparaisse à quelques
mois de cette élection est pas au moment
de l'élection c'est à dire que on vit
déjà une situation économique difficile
à les accentuer les choses allaient
rendre les choses encore plus difficiles
au niveau de la gestion du quotidien
ça me paraît dommageable parce que
celles et ceux qui lancent ces
opérations pourraient avoir attendu la
fin du mandat pour dire écoutez le
mandat s'est terminé
voilà ce que je peux vous dire j'ai
fonctionné comme ça j'ai respecté mes
engagements
j'ai pas toujours été d'accord mais je
m'étais engagé alors maintenant que
c'est terminé je vais vous dire il ya
des tas de choses qui auraient pas dû
être à mes yeux comme l ont été
et je vais vous dire ce que je pense de
ce qui s'est passé et ce que je souhaite
pour le futur mais pas attaquer
systématiquement parce que vous savez on
ne gagne rien dans une guerre dans un
combat tout le monde paie une forme de
conseils que vous dispensez aussi à
votre frère yan monplaisir quelque part
et je le lui dispense
enfin je lui dit vous savez mon frère
c'est mon frère il a ses façons de voir
c'est pas forcément les miennes
il a toujours été comme il est mais
personne ne le découvrent il a d'énormes
qualités mais il a aussi si un tas
défaut personne n'est parfait
si je vous dis que je suis pas fait je
suis un menteur et n'est capable donc
c'est vrai que tout le monde a ses
qualités ses défauts mais c'est un
conseil que je donne parce que vous
savez écouter
j'entendais ce matin encore sur une
télévision métropolitaine quelqu'un qui
citait les territoires d'outre-mer
qu'est-ce qu'il a cité la réunion la
guadeloupe il en va barder de la
martinique la martinique c'était c'était
la martinique qui étaient cités tout le
temps je me souviens yarbrough 20 ou 25
ans aujourd'hui on n'en parle plus
pourquoi qui est responsable de ça mais
nous mêmes nous mêmes les combats que
nous vivons regardez ces histoires de
statut qu'on casse vous croyez que c'est
bien de faire ce qu'on fait on tue on
casse notre histoire
moi j'ai l'intention avec les amis de
l'association du président magniant
ville de salé à case-pilote une un buste
de gaston monnerville vers le milieu de
l'année
parce que c'est la place gaston
monnerville mais je me demande est ce
qu'ils vont venir casser le bus le
gaston monnerville aussi où allons nous
pascale gaston monnerville il a été nous
le savons le deuxième personnage de
l'état une force énorme et oui mais cet
homme s'il est là demain on va casser la
statue sous prétexte qu'il a été le
deuxième personnage du sénat et que le
sénat y avait des lois si ça monsieur
on en est je sais plus on est dans ce
petit parti nick mais c'est dommage
et moi je suis un homme qui préfère la
paix je sais me défendre mais j'aime la
paix monsieur alors on va terminer avec
votre fonction votre mandat plutôt de
président du ce même le syndicat
martiniquais d'électrité de la
martinique
et notamment ce rendez-vous alors on va
pas trop dévoiler mais il ya un rendez
vous demain concernant la géothermie aux
anses d'arlet c'est un projet qui est là
depuis déjà plusieurs années et puis à
une première consultation de la
population
il ya quelques mois et demain il ya une
deuxième réunion de concertation parce
que parmi les possibilités d'avoir des
énergies renouvelables on sait qu'il ya
le vent l'éolien le soleil incinération
des déchets et cetera bagasse bois par
exemple pour voilà et puis donc dans le
programme de programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie d'un martinique le la ppe
est bien il ya aussi les potentiels
gisement géothermique absolument donc
allé à base de déjà mère là la
température des je vais vous dire que
personnel en show de la mer voilà
personnellement dans le cadre de mes
fonctions et des réunions que nous
tenons ensemble au pt m c'est à dire la
7ème et df l'ademe et le semaine je
considère que je suis celui qui a
relancé le projet de martiniquais parce
que la leur aux jeunes dominicains
existe mais c'est un projet qui est plus
lourd et aussi audi aussi mis au niveau
des investissements que de la partie
diplomatique vous savez c'est un état
des renvois la martinique
on est chez nous on a un gisement aux
anses d'arlet il a été repéré
on l'a plus ou moins mesuré le moment
est venu de faire chez nous ce qu'on
peut faire avec ce qu'on a
et effectivement en ce moment il ya un
travail
il ya eu des appels qui ont été lancés
il ya des sociétés qui ont répondu deux
sociétés autant que je sache on aurait
en fait ont manifesté leur intérêt
et c'est une source de d'énergie qui est
perdue tiff dur c'est pas quelque chose
qui va et vient sauf si on ne sait
jamais dans la vie rien n'est sûr
effectivement mais normalement c'est une
bonne source d'énergie et une fois
qu'elle est installée elle ne coûte pas
cher donc là on vous êtes toujours dans
la continuité donc d'essayer de
d'installer ce projet aux anses d'arlet
donc je le disais une seconde réunion de
concertation publique
va être organisée demain des anses
d'arlet qui est un homme très positifs
et qu'ils essaient de faire en sorte que
les anses d'arlet avancée formidable
wallace est prévue demain à 18 heures
voilà donc afin d'informer d'impliquer
les arlésiens et les martiniquais dans
les recherches exploratoires et ce
projet d'implantation d'une centrale
géothermique à petit ans voilà on a fait
le tour ce matin merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions rosiers merci de m'avoir
invité deux vagues de m'avoir permis de
m'exprimer auprès de la population
martiniquaise bonne journée à vous
monsieur caruge merci bonne journée
vous retrouvez jimmy damas
[Musique]